[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag spécial
municipal aujourd'hui on va parler du
séparatisme islamiste en france un débat
qui se durcit à l' approche des
élections
on en parle avec nos invités sur ce
plateau patrick mennucci ancien député
ps et conseiller municipal de marseille
face avoue pierre vermeren historien et
spécialiste du monde arabe hauteur de
dénis français notre histoire secrète
des liaisons franco arabe
frank o'hara pardon aux éditions albin
michel stéphane rozès président du cap
et enseignant à sciences po et à hec
ainsi que dominique de montvalon
éditorialiste politique merci à tous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france des mesures pour lutter contre le
séparatisme islamistes emmanuel macron
ne veut plus parler de communautarisme
pour ne pas stigmatiser les musulmans de
france à mulhouse le 18 février dernier
le chef de l'état a présenté son plan
pour lutter contre l'islam politique
un débat alimenté par les polémiques
notamment sur la présence des listes
communautariste aux municipales écoutez
le chef de l'état
notre ennemi et à ce titre de
séparatisme c'est à dire ce phénomène
que nous observons depuis des décennies
qui est une volonté de quitter la
république de ne plus en respecter les
règles d'un mouvement de repli qui en
raison de croyances et d'appartenance
vise à sortir du champ républicain et ça
ça n'est pas un culte dans la république
on ne peut pas accepter qu'on refuse de
serrer la main à une femme parce qu'elle
est femme dans la république on ne peut
pas accepter d'être que quelqu'un refuse
d'être soignés ou éduquer par quelqu'un
parce que c'est une femme dans la
république on ne peut pas accepter la
déscolarisation pour des raisons
religieuses de croyance dans la
république on ne peut pas exiger des
certificats de virginité pour se marier
dans la république
on ne doit jamais accepté que les lois
de la religion puisse être supérieure
aux lois de la république
et voilà pour la navfor du chef de
l'état patrick mennucci est ce que le
constat fait par emmanuel macron est
vraiment à ce point alarmant en france
oui je crois que le président de la
république dit des choses qui existent
mais ce que je constate c'est que il
faudrait dire les mots jusqu'au bout
quand on dit séparatisme ou
communautariste on va reparler je pense
qu'il ya un débat autour de tout ça mais
il faudrait ajouter islamistes parce que
le communautarisme je suis veut dire que
quelqu'un apprennent le puck 5e que des
gens apprennent le pachtoune ou qu'ils
aient les cours de cuisine africaine qui
est le nouvel an chinois
personne ne considérera que c'est un
danger pour la république ce qui est un
danger pour la république c'est ce
qu'ils ont décidé est qui et qui
théorisent le fait que la charia est
supérieure aux lois de la république
cela pose un problème à la république
parce qu'ils prétendent que leur façon
de vivre leurs règles juridiques leur
leurs habitudes doivent être supérieure
à la loi au code civil au code pénal à
la constitution c'est eux qui posent un
danger
parmi les musulmans de france qui sont
extrêmement minoritaires et donc nos
pros
nous avons là c'est qu'effectivement il
faut parler de tout ça agir et en même
temps ne pas 10 désignés les les
pratiquants ou les gens qui sont de
culture arabo musulmane comme les
ennemis de la république et c'est donc
une véritable difficulté c'est pour ça
je crois que le président de la
république parle de séparatisme parce
que ça lui permet de montrer qu'il y a
des joueurs effectivement qui veulent se
séparer je crois que ça vienne de là
vous voyez que ça fait vraiment la
différence entre les musulmans
je crois que ça fasse la différence en
tout cas dans la sémantique qui
l'emploie il pourra toujours expliquer
si on lui reproche de stigmatiser une
religion de dire non pas du tout ce
n'est pas une religion que si matt hill
je montre ce qui les tenants de d'une
pratique de cette religion au fond
l'islam c'est pas qu'une religion on le
sait il ya aussi des règles juridiques
bon voila il sait qu'il est qui qui les
emploient le problème c'est que comme
quand on a fait la loi de 1905 l'islam
n'existait pas sur le territoire
national donc on n'a jamais eu le débat
de fond qu'on n'a eu sur les îles et
l'israélite avec ça c'est la somme des
rennes c'est napoléon avec les
protestants et la différence c'est que
l'islam l'islam en soi et politiques
dominique de montvalon le l'islam prône
d'ailleurs un califat
le sait le système de l'om qui pose la
question de ce ne sont que des ce ne
sont que des mots mais je pense que les
mots utilisés ou proposée par le
président de la république sont
extrêmement importants alors je sais pas
si l'ensemble des français vont les
faire leur ces mots là quand on dit
quand on dit le communautarisme et il y
avait une ambiguïté parce que si je vous
ai bien entendu beaucoup de français se
sentent en communauté jusque là on
pourra dire on pourrait énumérer tous
ceux qui à un titre ou à un autre sur le
plan culturel historique personnel
sportif et autonome enfin voilà et donc
il y avait une ambiguïté global qu'est
ce que ça veut dire on met en cause de
communautarisme et moi j'aime bien être
ça me couper de personnes j'aime bien
être avec les gens de ma communauté qui
ont partagé la même histoire je sais pas
je pense au hasard mais il y en a
cinquante mille autres les français
d'algérie qui ici les anciens pieds
noirs qui ici se retrouve exactement
bref essai important de d'essayer
d'imposer ses sept ce dont il s'agit ce
ne suffira pas d'imposer le mot
séparatisme alors effectivement monsieur
le député je me permets de vous appeler
toujours monsieur le député vous pourrez
même pu m'appeler monsieur le conseiller
municipal puisque je suis pas qui a dit
je vous appellerai monsieur réfuté le
député cc c'est important alors est-ce
qu'il faut mettre le séparatisme
islamique
oui c'est bien lui qui est aujourd'hui
virtuellement tous ceux qui veulent
essayer de vivre leur aspiration à une
communauté à vivre en communauté à
l'écart des lois de la république sont
tous
c'est potentiellement coupables les
suspects de séparatisme évidemment il ya
une fraction des fractions de la
communauté musulmane est aujourd'hui à
des ambitions politiques séparatistes
qui sont absolument indiscutable juste
elle ajouté j'ajoute juste sur place et
ceux ci ce qui m'intéresse moi aussi
c'est que le jeu ne suis pas sûr sans
faire de procès d'intention que le
maquereau de 2017 aurait tenu ce
discours là en tout cas de l'ap a tenu
bon et je pense aussi que ça accélère
une prise de conscience globale parce
que je ne suis pas sûr que tous les
français de gauche de droite est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui en sont à ce
niveau de maturité au moins de
sémantique qui consiste à distinguer le
communautarisme de du séparatisme alors
il ya des mesures qui ont été annoncées
par emmanuel macron à mulhouse stéphane
rozès notamment la fin de l'accueil des
imams détacher il ya 300 imams détaché
en france chaque année les donc ce sont
les imams qui viendrait de turquie
d'algérie ou du maroc principalement
bonne mesure selon vous je ne suis pas
spécialiste de ces questions là mais
j'ai cru comprendre je parle sous le
contrôle de nos amis que des chats selon
les pays
des imams qui arrivent en france sont
plus ou moins suivi quant à leur
capacité de s'adapter aux règles de la
république et que selon les pays
d'origine
il ya déjà une différence ce qui me
semble à priori le plus important c'est
de considérer l'ensemble des imams et de
mettre dehors
or des mosquées ceux qui tiennent des
discours incompatible avec la république
et le type de socialité qui est le no
donc là il ya un problème effectivement
de fond avec derrière tout est question
de savoir mais alors qui encadrent qui
forme mais ce qu'il faut du coup amender
la loi de 1905 dont des problèmes un
tout petit peu complexe le président
mâcon à juste titre a voulu distinguer
les musulmans de ce qu'il appelle les
séparatistes mais nous sommes d'accord
ici pour dire que c'est au fond
l'islamisme politique
attention à ce que le terme séparatisme
ne s'adresse pas seulement aux
salafistes
parce qu'il ya aussi les frères
musulmans parce que il ya là
tactiquement deux types d'attitudes
assez différente je parle sous le
contrôle de nos amis les salafisme
semble-t-il sont clairement et
séparatistes e10 là où nous sommes
nous devons avoir en termes de croyance
et d'édiction de ce que nous voulons
nous ne devons pas prendre en compte ce
qu'est la république alors que les
frères musulmans eux ont une vision
beaucoup plus graduelle beaucoup plus
tactique il pénètre les les lieux d'
influence et y compris dans le débat sur
ce qu'on appellerait l'islamophobie
il attaque assez habilement par cette
thématique
l'idée qu' on ne pourrait pas critiquer
la religion musulmane alors que ça fait
des siècles 1-2 puis commencer par
rabelais ensuite voltaire la révolution
française qu'il a acté le fait de
pouvoir émettre une critique à l'égard
des d'une religion fait partie de la
socialité à la française qui ont
peut-être moins de signes extérieurs en
tout cas de reconnaissance les frères
musulmans par rapport aux salafistes
il y à 1800 imams recensés en tout cas
en france 250 2500 mosquée pardon est-ce
que la menace finalement de ces
salafistes et de ses frères musulmans et
du discours haineux pierre vermeren
vient de l'extérieur
non ce serait trop simple vous avez
alors d'abord il faut il faut qu on
détache l'idée qu'on a deux on associe
l'imam et la mosquée aux prêtres et à
l'église
en réalité l'islam c'est pas une
religion pas l'imam n'a pas le même rôle
que le prêtre il n'ya pas de clergé donc
projeté absolument à clergé déjà c'est
une première étape des hiérarchies il
n'y a pas de hiérarchie et le clergé ont
peu ils peuvent pratiquer les on peut
pratiquer l'islam sans imam c'est ce que
font d'ailleurs la majorité musulmans en
france
de fait
tous ces notions ne sert à rien par son
papa résoudre cela s'est passé sans
problème il ya 1800 imams comme vous
l'avez dit 80% sont étrangers ciblée sur
les imams étrangers envoyées par le
maroc l'algérie et la turquie
ça met dans le même sac si vous voulez
des choses assez différentes
vous avez d'un côté le projet d'art
dogan qui dit c'est que qu'on peut
considérer comme des chefs où le chef
des chefs musulmans dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui qui a fait des discours
très clair sur l'europe propos de
l'allemagne plus que la france mais en
disant qu'il était contre l'intégration
des turcs et des musulmans dans nos pays
et puis vous avez al'inverse et donc il
va promouvoir et la turquie a annoncé
qu'elle allait doubler le nombre d'imams
formés sur son territoire dans les
années qui viennent doxa et un coup
d'arrêt elle a assez nette
apparemment qui va être donnée dans le
cas du maroc et de l'algérie peut penser
ce qu'on veut c'est vrai que l'islam
fait partie du système politique
marocain et algérien par le fait mais
ces gouvernements sont en lutte contre
les salafistes et contre les frères
musulmans d'autre part donc ce sont des
imams qui a priori on peut leur
reprocher bien des choses mais ce sont
des imams qui sont formés pour lutter
contre le radicalisme donc si on se
focalise sur cette seule question
on voit qu'on a une réponse incomplète
alors c'est pas tout à fait le cas
puisqu'il ya des imams frères musulmans
qui sont formés en france il ya deux
instituts et apparemment l'un des deux à
aubervilliers a été récemment fermés sur
demande de l'administration donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya parallèlement une action
menée contre voyez donc
il faut se méfier des caricatures parce
que dès qu'on rentre un peu dans le
détail les choses sont tout de suite un
peu plus compliqué et patrick mennucci
les imams il ya aussi des hommes
français qui sont nés en france
justement et qui ont été injustement
pour compléter sur permettait sur
l'algérie moi je suis allé avec bernard
cazeneuve à alger pour voir et pour
signer bernard cazeneuve qui a signé un
accord pour ces imams et je peux vous
dire qu'il y a dans la sélection des
imams une présence de l'ambassade de
france il ya des choses qui se passent
au président de la république
au fond la caisse qui fait je crois
d'abord que c'est destiné à organe froid
très clairement parce qu'il ya un risque
sur les départements dans mon avis de
l'est de la france alsace moselle et
c'est exactement on a tout à fait aux
réseaux à mulhouse donc on a là
effectivement un problème sur les
algériens et marocains
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord je suis
en espagne le vrai problème c'est faux
pas d'interdît c'est au fond là on s'en
branle il y est ce que j'appelle moi
l'islam consulaires et là c'est l'islam
du consulat d'ukraine des ambassadeurs
c'est l'influencé de ces pays en france
la vraie question c'est comment la
république
titulaire de la laïcité et de la loi de
1905 à rim a créé une formation alors il
ya des choses qui ont été faites
puisqu'il existe aujourd'hui des débuts
c'est à dire des diplômes universitaires
qui sont destinés à des religieux il
existe le médiator c'est pas obligatoire
c'est obligatoire si vous êtes imum dans
une prison oui déjà
mais c'est aussi obligatoire pour le le
prg a cru bon voilà c'est pour avoir des
éléments dont il ya eu des choses de
faire passer un diplôme sur la laïcité
sur la laïcité
oui c'est à dire que vous devez associé
à votre pratique religieuse un diplôme
sur la laïcité ensuite vous avez ce
qu'avait proposé dominique de villepin
qui moi me paraît être la solution c'est
à dire
créée à strasbourg pourquoi strasbourg
parce que la loi de 1905 n'existe pas à
l'université de strasbourg financé par
l'état et bien une chaire voilà
universitaire d'islamologie qui pourrait
la constituent et construire une
intellectualisme et créer des jeunes qui
ensuite pourrait être à la fois des
religieux mais complètement intégré dans
les lois de la république
je veux dire je termine ça s'est jamais
fait ce que je suis en train de dire
puisqu'à en réalité sarkozy quand il est
arrivé à liquider le projet et les
choses se battaient ya du travail à
strasbourg autour de ça il ya une chair
mais il n'y a pas une
comment dire une grande utilisation de
la possibilité que nous donnent les
départements comme pour les curés
finalement non c'est pas comme écurie
c'est en fait si vous permettez il ya eu
sous françois hollande une mission de 3
disons juristes et universitaires qui
ont essayé de réfléchir à ce projet mais
ça supposerait et ça a été abandonné
parce que ça suppose une réforme de la
constitution parce que l'islam ne fait
pas partie des quatre trois ou quatre
religions qui aux quatre qui ont été
intégrés oui mais donc une affiche sous
l'ovation strasbourg où pouvaient nom et
prénom mais je parle bien de strasbourg
je parle de l'alsace écoutez je suis pas
juriste et sa supposée en l'état actuel
dès textes une réforme la corruption du
coup ça a été à bath et vous verrez je
vous dis après il ya un autre problème
c'est que les musulmans de france
vous savez il ya des transferts
financiers tout à fait considérable
chaque année qui sont organisés vers les
pays d'origine
ou non mais parce qu'on prend souvent
des finances banc de l'extérieur vers
l'intérieur
mais il ya les financements de
l'extérieur vers l'intérieur la
communauté si vous comparez le niveau de
vie des maghrébins en france où des
personnes d'origine maghrébine en france
ou doré ou musulmanes en france
bon par rapport au niveau de vie au
maghreb les très très élevé et pour
l'instant on fait élevé par des pays bas
ont fait élever des mosquées ont fait qu
on fait financer l'islam de france par
des populations et des pays très pauvres
auprès d'une population qui relativement
à un niveau de vie beaucoup plus élevé
le problème c'est pas tellement l'argent
c'est que dans la population à des
musulmans de france il ya très très peu
de candidats pour devenir imam souvent
vous parlez à des pères d'origine
maghrébine ils vous disent je suis pas
venu en france pour que mon fils
devienne imams et là il ya un problème
culturel à la fois sur cette envie la
difficulté à imaginer ses enfants imams
et le peu de gens qui ont envie de le
devenir
et deuxièmement la question je dirais
bayer la question du financement parce
qu'en disant finalement on attend que ça
vienne de l'extérieur que ça vienne du
gouvernement français que ça vienne
d'alsace ou que ça vienne des pays du
maghreb ou du moyen-orient
donc là il ya là tout une question
culturelle sur laquelle il faut
travailler qui n'est pas évidente et
encore une fois l'islam c'est pas
forcément une religion avec des imams et
autres christianisme l'état français en
tout cas qui a recensé 47 quartier de
reconquête républicaine permis c 47
quartier de dix sept territoires de
lutte contre la radicalisation
il y a des grandes villes comme
marseille ou paris 1 qui ont qui font
part sous deux de ces 17 territoires
maubeuge a également été cité notamment
par le ministre de l'éducation il y à il
ya quelques jours écoutez le maubeuge
pour vous donner un autre exemple pour
profiter des endroits où je suis allé
récemment garges les gonesse qui est
souvent cité ce sont des endroits où où
certains ont en quelque sorte pris le
pouvoir dans la rue alors certains ont
pris le pouvoir dans la rue on est allé
à maubeuge justement pour un recueillir
la réaction des habitants dans certains
quartiers justement dont par le ministre
à écouter les habitants de maubeuge il
n'a qu'à venir ici vivre ici il va
savoir ce que c'est
au jour d'aujourd'hui vous avez envie
tous ensemble tout ce que vous avez vu
vous regardez il ya on est tous mélangés
je pense
je pense qu'il y en a quand même bon
savon peut jeter ailleurs fait 25 ans
que j'habite ici la sueur l'épinette et
aucun souci franchement envie tous
ensemble et aucun souci on a toujours
considéré les hauts de france comme une
région retarder ou il y avait à un seuil
de pauvreté très bas et on ne fait pas
attention aux gens qui vivent et on ne
vient pas se rendre compte par soi même
de ce qu'il peut y avoir sur place
alors il ya 150 villes également qu'ils
ont été répertoriés comme étant
potentiellement pas des villes mais des
zones plutôt des quartiers dès qu'ils
sont on le voit sur cette carte qui ont
été notamment un désigné par la dgs i
comme potentiellement séparatistes
stéphane rozès ça ça se limite
finalement à des quartiers pas forcément
des villes ou des villages et d'ailleurs
ont parfois dans des zones où on s'y
attend le moins envie
avant l'émission ont discuté avec
patrick mennucci sur des cas par exemple
en arrière et charles suffit souvent
qu'il ya un imam y compris converti un
qui a une certaine influence pour qu'il
arrive à agréger autour de lui donc
c'est vraiment la présence d'un imam qui
fait que à saint louis
c'est un ensemble voyez alors là on a vu
un reportage c'est bien naturel et je
parle sous le contrôle de dominique de
montvalon qui a dirigé une grande
rédaction au parisien les les habitants
n'aiment pas être stigmatisés par la
presse et par le national donc il ya une
réaction patriotique normal mais
néanmoins des critiques de ceux qui
suivent un peu de ces questions là c'est
considérer plutôt que l'état est en
retard et on a fermé le rapport à la
menace plutôt que l'averse prenons des
éléments purement objective puisque les
municipales arrive un jeu passe votre
contrôle mais dans une cinquantaine de
bureaux de vote les listes
communautarise font plus de 10% donc il
ya des facteurs une réelle différence
qui joue très peu très peu de paria sur
l'allemand bien sûr mais au fond de
communautarisme ne s'exprime pas
seulement par les dix ça faisait 10 mai
par l'influent sont le bois sur
certaines fautes politiques à 1
ivre a été fait par exemple sur bobigny
sur l' influence par exemple auprès de
guy lagarde que parce que peuvent avoir
les phénomènes de communautarisme sur
les phénomènes politiques
beaucoup pointent certains au sein de la
france a soumis ce qu'on appelle des
islamo gauchiste donc le communautarisme
prend des formes effectivement très
diverses
et puisqu'on parle des territoires c'est
l'occasion de dire que la réponse à
l'islamisme politique ne peut pas être
seulement de nature religieuse ou
encadrements rue dieu même si il ne faut
pas mésestimer la force même du
théologico politique c'est bien parce
que la république peine à donner un
avenir commun à nos enfants sur les
territoires parisiens vides en tout cas
ça répond henvic ans quand le président
macron interrogé devant des millions de
français demande à la question d'un de
vos confrères d où emmener vous les
français dit
des historiens le diront mais il faut
bien comprendre que ce qui fait la
république chez nous c'est le fait de
dessiner un avenir commun c'est de dire
quel est le modèle français aujourd'hui
demain et donc ça ne peut pas on a
raison de parler de la lutte contre le
terrorisme des réseaux les influences
étrangères la turquie le talent le qatar
l'arabie saoudite
il faut le faire bien sûr mais il ya
aussi des choses qu'on voit dans les
quartiers l'heureux le retrait des
services publics et le fait qu' un
certain nombre de nos jeunes ont le
sentiment que au fond les islamistes
offres y insère l'internet par une
cohérence entre la pratique du quotidien
de l'observance et puis le rapport aux
autres donc en un mot c'est une palette
de mesures qui permettent de répondre
sur le fond à la montée de ce grave
danger que représente islamisme
politique effectivement un et ça répond
à un vide dominique de montvalon on a vu
jean mieux jean michel blanc coeur
parler d'éducation et 46 me
étaient contraints en 2018 c'est + 17 %
par rapport à 2010 est c'est ça aussi
séparatisme c'est ne plus mettre ses
enfants dans les écoles de la république
c'est ça fait partie du problème
ça fait incontestablement partie d un
problème que je pense à ce que vous
venez de dire sur il ya une palette de
mesures à prendre mais avant ça au
complémentairement ce qui m'intéresse
dans la situation actuelle c'est que là
les français semble-t-il prenne enfin
conscience du problème parce que il faut
pas se tromper alors on est en retard
on a le droit d'en parler et il faut
avancer il faut avancer d'autant plus
sur ce précipité qu' on est très en
retard mais il ya encore peu je pense
que c'est encore le cas dans à gauche à
droite ailleurs aujourd'hui c'était un
sujet qui était tabou dont on n'avait
pas le droit de parler et on suspectait
qui que ce soit qui évoquait ce ce
dossier-là de d'une dérive immédiate ou
à venir c'est il s'agit quand même que
la république soit défendu et que les
règles du vivre ensemble soit rappelé à
tous et personne n'en est exclu certains
peuvent dire moi j'ai pas droit autant
que d'autres et c'est un autre problème
personne est de dire qu'il y à quelques
forces pas nombreuses mais qui progresse
qui sont effectivement dans une logique
dans une logique séparatiste
ce qu'ils disent à ce dont ils sont
proches et parfois effectivement ils
sont proches dans la vie quotidienne
on a pu quelquefois comparer alors
comparaison n'est pas raison on a pu
quelquefois comparer le le communisme
municipal de la grande époque avec qui a
disparu pratiquement aujourd'hui avec ce
que peuvent faire un certain nombre
d'islamistes mais cette comparaison ne
nous lie pas les mains
pierre vermeren vous parlez dans votre
ville d'ailleurs de dénis français par
rapport à cette question
explications c'est ce dont on parlait à
l'instant pour revenir un mot sur le ce
que disait le président macron au début
j'ai entendu qu'il a beaucoup insisté
sur le rappel à la loi en quelque sorte
c'est à dire sur la nécessité de d'obéir
et de respecter les lois en vigueur
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
considérable c'est à dire que on a
accepté des choses qui ne sont pas
acceptables par exemple tout prêtre sait
très bien que s'ils marie un couple
catholique ou autre enfin catholique en
l'occurrence sans être passer
préalablement par la mairie il va avoir
des gros problèmes avec la justice
or on n'est pas le cas or c'est pas le
cas et c'est quelque chose de
parfaitement admis jusqu'à nos jours
parce qu'on vit au fond c'est pas
vraiment un mariage c'est pas vrai c'est
vrai oui bon c'est pas vraiment sérieux
voyez il ya un problème de prise au
sérieux cercle déni c'est pas forcément
qu'on veut pas voir c'est qu'au fond on
ne regarde même pas et donc là le fait
de regarder va considérer va nous amener
est immanquablement à regarder
finalement que peut-être l'obligation de
respecter la loi dans tout un tas de
domaines et tout à fait central quant au
séparatisme
on peut aussi savez les frères musulmans
ils sont pas du tout séparatistes ils
sont plutôt je dirais envahissant il
faut lui faire intégrer
il va donc mots on va on va continuer
d'en parler rester avec nous bien sûr on
continue ce débat sur le séparatisme
islamiste en france comment lutter
contre ce phénomène et pourquoi s'est-il
implantées sur le territoire on en débat
dans quelques minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
le pire je pense en tout cas
politiquement pour l'union européenne
c'est que ça se passe bien pour les
anglais et y aura peut-être un effet
boule de neige si l'italie sort vous
avez un éclatement de l'euro et de
l'union européenne dans les mois qui
suivent
l'euro s'est pas seulement un projet
financier c'est un projet politique
aussi le rhône fonctionne pas sinon on
n'aurait pas eu un second elle a lu avec
la grèce je suis passé n'ont pas
d'accord sur l'échec de l'euro ou
maintient la grèce en commun à mon avis
une bonne chose vous pouvez pas vous
réjouir d'avoir pays qui est sous
perfusion sous assistance respiratoire
en permanence
[Musique]
à
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable nos soldats
ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant est ce que
peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
promis par les pays vieux st gall c'est
là où les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec patrick
mennucci ancien député ps et conseiller
municipal à marseille pierre vermeren
historien et spécialiste du monde arabe
stéphane rozès président du cap et
enseignant à sciences po et à hec ainsi
que dominique de montvalon éditorialiste
politique
61% des français pensent que l'islam est
incompatible avec les valeurs de la
société française c'est le résultat d'un
sondage ifop paru en octobre dernier
près de huit sondés sur dix pensent que
la laïcité est menacée
l'ifop qui avait publié à cette période
une grande enquête sur le comportement
des musulmans de france
voyez les précisions de notre
journaliste quel point technique et on
en débat c'est une des rares études qui
fait le point sur les pratiques et
représentations des musulmans de france
le sondage montre que les pratiques
religieuses se seraient renforcés ces
trente dernières années les musulmans
seraient aujourd'hui 38 % à se rendre à
la mosquée chaque vendredi contre
seulement 16% en 1989 en 2019
il serait 66% à respecter le jeûne du
ramadan contre 60% auparavant en 1989
35% des personnes de confession
musulmane déclaré boire de l'alcool ils
ne sont plus que 21 % aujourd'hui
le sondage révèle aussi que 58% des
musulmans achètent systématiquement de
la viande halal et 14% la plupart du
temps 82% des sondés pensent ainsi qu'on
devrait pouvoir manger halal dans les
cantines scolaires concernant le voile
presque 31 % de femmes musulmanes
affirme le portées contre 24 % en 2003
et 59% des personnes interrogées
estiment que l'interdiction du port du
voile intégral dans la rue est plutôt
une mauvaise chose
68% pensent en outre qu'une jeune fille
devra avoir la possibilité de porter le
voile au collège ou au lycée
un point sur la perception de la laïcité
la pratique de l'islam doit elle être
adaptée et aménagée sur certains points
pour être conforme à la laïcité à la
française
oui pour 41 % de musulmans tandis que
37% pensent linverse 27% des personnes
interrogées estiment que la charia
devrait s'imposer par rapport aux lois
de la république
mais attention ce pourcentage mérite
d'être détaillé les musulmans français
de naissance
ce ne sont que 18% à le penser contre
41% pour les musulmans étrangers
l'étude des chiffres de ce sondage
dévoile par ailleurs une vraie diversité
de la population musulmane tendances et
opinions que dans ces pratiques
une diversité qui varient également
selon la catégorie socioprofessionnelle
et l'origine géographique des parents
donc voilà pour cette enquête publiée
par par l'ifop 27% des personnes
interrogées sont d'accord avec l idée
que la charia devrait s'imposer par
rapport aux lois de la république c'est
quand même un tiers le chiffre est quand
même inquiétant patrick mennucci je
crois que s'est inquiétée en fait nous
le savons mais ça veut dire que ce débat
n'est pas là pour rien ça veut dire que
ce qu'a dit le président de la
république
il était temps de commencer à bouger et
ça veut dire que demain il faudra que
les municipalités qui pour l'instant
sont encore on peut convenir un peu
frileuse après les municipales je pense
que des choses vont se passer je pense
qu'il par exemple quand le président de
la république parle c'est un autre
domaine c'est de la cité de vigilance à
l'égard de radicalisation mais là quand
vous pensez que la charia est supérieure
aux lois de la république vous êtes
quand même pas loin de la radicalisation
qu'évidemment faut quand même le
signifier et je pense qu après les
élections municipales il faudra quand
même que les municipalités rentrer dans
l'addition passe quand vous parlez de la
société de vigilance qui sont les
premiers qui doivent être vigilants
c'est quand même les collectivités c'est
quand même les élus mm ceux qui
connaissent plus la population et qui
doit être le plus en capacité de parler
d'expliquer je pense que dominique de
montvalon le disais on parle pas
beaucoup de ces choses là
or je pense qu'aujourd'hui moi c'est
pour ça que je suis pas critique sur ce
qu'a fait le président de la république
je critique sur beaucoup d'autres sujets
mais sur là-dessus non parce que je
pense que ça le mérite de commencer à
poser la question et à permettre demain
à des édiles à des mères à des adjoints
à des jeunes qui vont dans une salle de
sport de ne pas supporter comme par
exemple comme diffuse d'aider des
versets du coran pendant qu'on fait de
la boxe et que ça permet aussi aux
municipalités de dire à bettié coûté si
vous voulez une subvention les gars
c'est très simple mais on va d'abord
signé une charte de la laïcité comme l'a
fait xavier bertrand
ça suffit mais je pense que ça suffit
pas mais on commence à dire le droit
c'est un point d'appui c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce que disent c'est
ce que disent certains hommes de mer
est-ce que ce que nous entendons et
georges fenech puisqu'on me fais
beaucoup de réunions avec eux c'est
qu'il voudrait que ce soit les plaques
par exemple qui impose la charte de la
laïcité de façon à ce que quand ils
arrivent dans leur conseil municipal
ils disent mais moi aussi éclaté alors
dit non il faut passer parce que c'est
des choses comme ça qu'il faut faire en
l'état était bon d'abord remarqué
général sur votre commentaire qui est
très bien fait les études d'opinion ont
montré parmi des français musulmans
une montée effectivement du
communautarisme ou du séparatisme le
fait que le tiers des français musulmans
souhaitent la charia c'est à dire le
fait que la loi religieuse prime sur la
loi de la république
c'est une évolution dans le temps qui
est préoccupante
deuxièmement il ya quand même un écart
entre le rapport de force entre les
musulmans dits modérés d'un côté de
l'hôtel isis qu'en pensent les français
comparent ciation est ce que pensent et
français près de trois français sur
quatre pensent que la religion musulmane
n'est pas adaptée à la république
or quand même et aux 10 la religion
musulmane l'islam voilà ils font pas la
différence voilà ils font pas
différences pourquoi parce que
malheureusement dans les médias et dans
la réalité
ceux qui parmi les musulmans s'exprime
le plus ce sont des gens qui sont
borderline avec l'islamisme
troisièmement dans les quartiers ceux
qui font régner les pressions sur les
musulmans quant aux tenues
vestimentaires ce sont également les
islamistes de sorte que dans tout un tas
d'endroits les maires et même des
musulmans demandent à l'état d'être d'un
point de vue régalien très clair et net
or l'état allait au contraire
de moins en moins alors le début ça a
été selon moi la sphère de creil mais
patrick mennucci a raison quand il ya
des rapports de force sur le terrain ou
des minorités font des pressions sur les
élus il faut qu'il y ait des normes qui
soit rappelée y compris au plan étatique
parce que c'est notre tradition
nationale dans d'autres pays ce sont les
régions ce sont les collectivités
territoriales qui font une communauté de
départ chez nous c'est bildt à la
référence et c'est pour ça que je suis
un peu moins je trouve que le président
macron a beaucoup tardé et je trouve que
les positions qu'il a prises sont pour
moi 13 à minima et cette année
l'assemblée la berge dans ce cas là il a
semblé le faire sous la pression bien
sûr bien sûr mais je dirais les français
sombraient publica et nos élites sont
moins le plus démocrates que
républicaines et la cc d'un certain
point de vue les français qui demandent
que l'état fasse respecter la république
parlait de pressions sur les élus escape
a aussi des réflexes électoraliste
dominique de montvalon les danses dans
des communes en essonne notamment ou au
train
sans en mettre une plus en lumière
qu'une autre mais les maires s'adapte
aussi parce que ce sont des électeurs
donc il ferme les yeux
il ya incontestablement des des
complaisances ou en tout cas des élus
qui qu'il reporte à plus tard des
décisions qu'ils annoncé qu'ils n'osent
qui ne s'estime pas en état de prendre
aujourd'hui mais oui je pense aussi un
mot c'est une vérité sur le sondage que
je suis très intéressant que vous avez
montré j'ajoute de me permettrait
d'ajouter une interprétation
supplémentaires papa central né
supplémentaires aujourd'hui dans la
france telle qu'elle est les musulmans
en général en parle pas des salafistes
et des islamistes radicaux les musulmans
en général ont tant de mal ça ne pas
dire faut pas être exigeant vis-à-vis de
nos ont tant de mal à trouver leur place
ils ont le sentiment d'être mêlé
attendent amalgame que je me demande
dans quelle mesure lorsqu un sondeur via
leur poser une une question et ne
choisissent pas des positions les plus
radicales dont je me dont j'ajoute que
je me demande si elle pas la charia si
ça passait dans le ce qu'à dieu ne
plaise mais l'effet est ce qu'il le
maître avec autrement dit il ya une
petite dimension
je ne renie pas sa partie de leurs
croyances puisque vous m'exclus et je
vais vous opposé des réponses à un
questionnaire que m'envoyer des réponses
qu'ils soient où qu'ils soient les plus
les plus provocatrices et qui vont vous
déranger pour vous obliger à vous poser
des questions après tout j'arrête là
dessus je veux juste dire ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce que nous vivons ce
que traduit votre votre débat
aujourd'hui c'est que ça a tardé chez
makro j'ai beaucoup d'autres je suis pas
encore sûr que la prise de conscience
soit absolument générale dans l'ensemble
des responsables de tous ordres
municipaux régionaux nationaux mais il
ya le début d'une prise de conscience on
peut regretter qu'elle n'ait pas
commencé plus tôt mais c'est il était
temps il est il est juste temps on est
heureux il est encore temps il est
encore temps avec la pizza au local et
sans amalgame
on va écouter valérie pécresse qui a
fait un diagnostic elle trouve que les
mesures du président sont plutôt
incomplète elle
elle parle du financement justement
étrangers des mosquées elle voudrait que
soit appliqué à ce financement la règle
des partis politiques écoutent et là il
se pose le diagnostic du président est
incomplet et donc ses remèdes sont
largement insuffisants je propose d'en
finir avec le financement étranger des
mosquées en appliquant au lieu de culte
la règle en vigueur pour les partis
politiques ni un état étranger ni une
personne étrangère sauf si elles
résident en france n'a le droit de
financer un parti
voilà pour le constat vous êtes d'accord
avec sa pierre vermeren est ce qu on
sait pas la seule source
évidemment du séparatisme mais est-ce
qu'on pourrait couper les vivres aux
mosquées justement quand les
financements sont extérieures la loi de
laïcité en france elle fait reposer le
financement des cultes par les fidèles
donc les fidèles
si vous prenez le budget de l'église
catholique ça doit être 7 ou 800
millions d'euros ils sont financés par
les fidèles
et c'est vrai que on en parlait tout à
l'heure il ya quand même si vous voulez
un problème dont on parle peu de dans la
nature de l'islam ou des mythes d islam
en france c'est que c'est un islam
comparer surtout si on le pose aux
autres grandes religions c'est un islam
très prolétarien en fait et on en
parlait à propos de la radicalisation la
radicalisation comme vous disiez dans
les cantons va interroger les gens dans
les banlieues il ya des gens qui font
régner l'ordre et c'est parce que c'est
un islam de classes populaires de classe
prolétarienne et c'est un islam donc qui
de ce point de vue là n'a pas les
verrous ou les tabous de des classes
moyennes et où la bourgeoisie ce que la
bourgeoisie musulmane d'abord il ya
toute la fraction on dit que quand on
interroge les chrétiens ont dit
d'origine chrétienne on demande jamais
aux musulmans d'origine musulmane
considère tout le monde musulman même un
athée musulmans le met dans les
musulmans ce que plus tard il ya des
gens il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
d'origine musulmane cela on n'en parle
pas mais donc parmi les musulmans y
arrive souvent la bourgeoisie musulmane
llc exfiltré parce que elle va elle se
met en arrière de cet islam violent
beaucoup ont fui l'algérie pour ne pas
retomber dans ses errances et puis il ya
le soufisme le soufisme on n'en parle
jamais c'est très important et ça se
passe dans les appartements y a pas
besoin d'image cet islam là ne pose pas
de problème donc je reviens au
financement le l'argent et
l'organisation de la bourgeoisie
musulmane manque et du coup on a un
islam prolétarien qui est séduit par des
investisseurs ou des acteurs
internationaux qui vont trouver dans le
golfe wire ou en turquie est sacrée
quelque chose et donc couper les vivres
ça mettrait peut-être la communauté
musulmane de france dans toute sa
diversité face à ses responsabilités
donc là la solution mérite pour le moins
d'être étudié alors c'est un islam
en tout cas le séparatisme islamique se
manifeste aussi par le biais des des
associations comment faire la différence
entre des associations qui prônent
évidemment de séparatisme et celles qui
sont là aussi pour aider les les
personnes dans des quartiers défavorisés
gabriela talent à son idée là dessus il
a beaucoup travaillé en amont de la
visite des manuels macron à mulhouse
justement pour maintenir ces
associations qui selon lui sont la clé
pour sortir du séparatisme ecoutez-le
affirmé que les associations ne sont pas
un coût c'est pas un coup c'est pas un
boulet c'est une chance et c'est quelque
chose qui rapporte ça rapporte vous
l'avez dit économiquement c'est 1,8 je
crois si je me trompe pas millions
d'emplois des emplois qui sont non
délocalisables
a priori donc c'est des emplois robuste
dans notre pays c'est la création de
richesse du coup et c'est aussi des
coûts évités pour les pouvoirs publics
associations donc les associations il
faut les encourager et gagna la talent
or patrick mennucci il ya des
associations qui entretient le
séparatisme et je suis pas bien compris
ce que disaient les associations général
vient me semble important c'est les
associations la home descend très
rapidement au niveau local c'est à dire
l association à part des grandes
fédérations de l'éducation populaire qui
pose pas de problème de ce genre de
choses on va être dans un territoire il
va ya voir l'association de foot de 2,2
de lutte de judo a laissé dans ses
actions c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que
je dis qu'il faut donner aux maires les
moyens de faire d'obliger parce que moi
je suis pour la charte mais non pas
qu'ils viennent de la municipalité
mais je suis pour que l'état impose aux
municipalités une charte à partir du
moment où vous suivants sur des
municipalités aux régions et aux
départements
il ya des exemples aujourd'hui nous
avons un certain nombre de communes et
de régions je parlais de nos deux héros
de france qui le font ce qui est très
important c'est de noter que là où il ya
des problèmes de main mise de
l'islamisme politique il faut casser le
système alors c'est où
mais je vais vous dire aujourd'hui les
jeunes qui se dit très inquiet c'est pas
la fédération des sports de glace
c'est la fédération 2-1 par d'autres
trésors vous avez raison excusez moi
mais c'est vrai que c'est d'autres
réseaux qui sont pas plus
harper peu plus entre débat c'est un
débat mais je dis c'est pas la
fédération française de rugby pour dire
les choses mais le foot le judo la lutte
caractères ou laisse le karaté tous les
sports de combat tous les sports de coma
vous avez des problématiques et ses
fédérations là doivent être aidés par le
ministère des sports doit être suivi et
on doit à mon avis quand on donne une
subvention que ce soit au niveau central
pour la fédération d'aucun que ce soit
au niveau local d'une municipalité d'une
région d'avoir une charte de la laïcité
à chanter ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que l'on fait pas prier
dans la dans la salle oh mais pas de
verser les hommes et les femmes sont
séparés un endroit dans les vestiaires
mais ailleurs
voilà il dit soan semble pas d'odeur
aménagé pour les pirates d'euros mais il
faut il faut non mais ça les heures
aménagé pour les piscines c'est vraiment
la dernière chose qu'il faut faire
il me semble a été fait c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien donc je pense que là sur
les associations
c'est ça qu'il faut faire après dans les
associations culturelles
les questions ne sont pas tellement il
s'est plutôt dans les centres sociaux
etc
vous pouvez trouver de l'entrisme plus
des frères musulmans que des salafistes
parce que les salafistes
ils sont déguisés ils arrivent vous les
voyez ils ont un pantalon qui arrive à
ça du sol
ils ont une barbe ils ont voté les
frères musulmans vous les voyez pas ils
sont avec vous voyez comme nous devons
savoir s'ils ratent une veste a donc je
crois vraiment que les associations à
thala réseau sur le responsable
important mais c'est un des hameaux où
il faut lutter contre le communautarisme
séparatistes et des contrôles forcément
mais je pense que je pense qu'une charte
de la laïcité obligatoires ça permet
déjà de donner aux financeurs m papier
monsieur machin alors moins là on s'est
vraiment ballon vous présidez
l'association dont vous allez signer la
alors vous allez lire si c'est vous
qu'ils me proposaient j'estime que vous
allez lire et on va vous dire un certain
nombre de choses il faut l'écrire
il faut que la charte le saura ce qu'il
faut des sanctions en cas de manquement
justement parce que sa piste
voilà sa caution elle est connue vous
avez perdu votre source
vous avez plus d'argent les crises qui
frappent aussi dans cette étude de
l'ifop c'est que ce sont les jeunes
français qui sont les plus croyants ceux
qui ont le plus à la mosquée donc c'est
un phénomène
finalement qui ne date pas du
ddd génération précédente se sont
historiquement y compris sur le port du
bois dont vous parlais tout à l'heure le
voile n'existait pas ou quasiment pas il
ya une trentaine d'années donc ça veut
donc dire que d'islamisme as politique à
sa dynamique propre théologico politique
mais c'est sur fond d'une crise de la
république dans l'écart entre ces
principes liberté égalité fraternité de
laïcité
et puis une réalité de terrain y compris
le risque à remy nation dès qu'on porte
un nom arabo musulman qui effectivement
pose un véritable problème de les jeunes
sont évidemment ceux qui sont les plus
en tension entre des aspirations
légitimes à avoir un avenir en affamant
et puis une réalité qui se dérobe pour
eux et si les islamistes dans les
prisons dans des mosquées dans les
quartiers obtiennent un succès plus
grand auprès des jeunes c'est que il
qu'est ce qu'ils leur disent ils leur
disent tu écartelée tu as des
aspirations mais tu vois bien que la
république dit des choses et ne tient
pas ses promesses sur dix on va
s'occuper de toi et on va s'occuper toi
et je veux vous avez mentionné aussi les
dimensions sociale dans les quartiers il
ya un encadrement il ya une aide ilya
militantisme est donc cette dynamique de
l'islamisme politique pour les jeunes
représentent une sorte de salut qui
n'est pas seulement à salut sociales
politiques mais aussi religieux chez ma
place j'ai ma place je ne suis pas
seulement un individu isolé
je suis dans nulle a considéré je suis
dans la communauté je suis dans mon
match et j'ai avec moi des frères j'ai
avec moi des soeurs et nous partageons
ensemble une pratique qui ne donne une
place dans une société où ça semble être
avec un bourg soir pierre vermeren oui
non mais c'est un phénomène qui a des
racines et des composantes en france et
en europe certainement mais c'est aussi
un phénomène international c'est à dire
que l'arrêt islamisation des populations
elle a lieu dans l'ensemble du bassin
méditerranéen
elle bénéficie de vecteur technologiques
très puissant qui n'existait pas il ya
20 ans l'internet les réseaux sociaux
les télévisions par satellite ça remonte
à un petit peu plus longtemps mais tout
ça ça en gros 20 25 ans et donc sa
sympathie puissamment parce que des
acteurs à l'extérieur qui envoie comme
on l'a vu au moment de la fameuse radio
d'el-qaïda malheureusement ou des
services leur fameux service de
communication qu'ils avaient ils ont un
journal était très bon donc ça c'est
très puissant et ça vient percuter une
réalité sociale en france qui a aussi
beaucoup changé depuis un quart de
siècle c'est à dire la constitution de
milieux géographiques ou institutionnels
totalement homogène
quand vous êtes dans un lycée où il ya
90 % de personnes musulmane ou d'origine
musulmane ou anciennement musulmane peu
importe mais qu'ils sont ensemble et qui
du coup sont pris en main par des
entrepreneurs religieux sur place qui
n'ont pas besoin d'être très nombreux
qui eux mêmes peuvent s'appuyer sur tout
un environnement
le club de foot je parle pas de la
prison bien sûr mais tout un tas de
l'institution là la ville parfois le
quartier qui peut être très large
ben vous avez la création d'enclavés au
moins imaginaire mais parfois plus et
comme non il ya tout un contexte et que
yahoo
en plus des gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur directement ou indirectement
et qui vont faire leur miel parce que
c'est savez c'est un business très
agressif cia du marketing
un marketing religieux agressif
commercial puissant et il ya des acteurs
qui jouent c'est dans l'adn de la
religion si musulmane peut-être d'être
davantage axé sur la charité sur
l'entraînent message
je ne m'attarderai pas de ce côté là
mais il est temps que là il est temps
que la république donc les républicains
auxquels les musulmans ou les français
d'origine musulmane sont son sont
invités à s'associer à ceux des
complexes se décomplexe complètement et
qu'ils soient réaffirmer les valeurs qui
nous sont communes de la république en
ce sens au passage je serai un des
signataires votre charte de la laïcité
je trouve ça excellent vous avez dit au
début de l'émission présent qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
éventuellement revoir la loi sur la
laïcité la de 1905 les crues combat je
veux pas relancer le débat mais l'achat
sur la laïcité
bravo voilà je le dernier mot on a
vraiment le temps on va passer à notre
sondage à les résultats de notre sondage
en ligne tout de suite
[Musique]
et on a posé la question sur nos réseaux
sociaux le plan contre le séparatisme
religieux d'emmanuel macron est-il un de
l'enfumage électorale de une réelle
volonté politique et bien vous avez les
résultats qui s'affichent à l'écran une
manoeuvre électorale pour 95% des
français qui ont du mal à croire que ces
mesures en tout cas seront efficaces
peut-être la vôtre proposé perryman chi
seras tu là ce sera davantage efficace
merci beaucoup en tout cas pour ce débat
messieurs merci d'avoir accepté de venir
sur arte france à l'info à suivre à
rester avec nous discuter
[Musique]
l'europe la france aujourd'hui on a du
mal à comprendre ce qui s'y passe les
chiffres sont bons
personne n'est content c'est à dire que
la désindustrialisation de la france
très très fort